PROFESSOR: All right, welcome.
We have some fun origami
topics today, mostly
related to a topic
called pleat folding.
General idea of pleat
folding is to fold
alternating mountains and
valleys back and forth.
And you can do a lot of cool
things with pleat folding,
and that's what I want
to talk about today.
In particular, this
model is usually
called the hyperbolic
paraboloid.
It's pretty simple.
You start with a square paper.
You fold this crease
pattern, which
is concentric squares
alternating mountain
and valley, and you
fold the diagonals,
alternating mountain and valley.
You crush it all
together, you'll
get this sort of x-shape.
And you sort of let
go, give it a twist,
and it pops into this
saddle form, which
looks a lot like a
hyperbolic paraboloid, which
is one of the standard
saddle surfaces.
It's approximating a hyperbolic
paraboloid, we think,
or we thought, and that's
why it's called that.
So you should all
try this at home.
It's a great model.
It's very cool.
It's an example of
something I like
to call self-folding origami
because the paper basically
folds itself.
You put in a very simple crease
pattern, concentric squares.
What could be simpler than that?
And yet you get this really
cool 3D form automatically.
Physics, in some sense, is
finding this form for us.
You can take this
pleating idea and apply it
to many different
crease patterns.
Another fun one if you have
a compass lying around,
to score circles is you just
crease concentric circles,
alternating mountain and valley.
In this case, you
also need to cut out
a circular hole in the center.
Then you get a
different saddle form,
which we don't know
exactly what it is.
Let's see, I have some various
fun things to talk about here.
So what's going on with paper--
if I take a piece of paper,
paper is an elastic material.
It remembers that
it was made flat.
It likes to be flat.
If I curl a paper a
little bit, for example,
it flattens back out.
That's elastic memory.
If however, I crease
a piece of paper,
then that's called a
plastic deformation
beyond the yield
point of the material.
This works in sheet metal
also, lots of materials.
I've effectively changed
the memory of the paper.
It now wants to stay bent.
If I try to unfold it, it
goes back to some angle.
Depending on how
hard I crease it,
it will go to a sharper angle.
So that's basically
what's going on.
In these surfaces, where
we crease the paper,
it wants to stay bent.
Where we don't crease the
paper, it wants to stay flat.
It can't do all of those
things, but physics
finds an equilibrium
among all those forces.
So we simulated
that some years ago.
This is with architecture
undergrad Jenna Fizel
and Professor John
Ochsendorf, architecture.
So on the right of
each of these examples,
we have photographs of real
models, pleated foldings,
a hyperbolic paraboloid,
squares, hexagon,
octagon, just not so pretty.
But we re-created that physical
model with a virtual model
just using some
spring approximation
to the forces I described.
And here's an approximation
to a circle, where we just
took a really big regular n-gon.
This is real circles
and the simulation.
So this confirms that what
I said is actually true.
Those are the only
forces you need to model,
and you get an
approximation of what
really happens in real life.
So instead of folding
real paper in this way,
you could simulate it.
Cool.
Here is that simulator in
action with pleated hexagons,
just to show you
what it looks like.
So the creases are trying
to become more bent,
at this point have
reached equilibrium,
and you get your 3D form.
Once you have that
3D form, so you
have a virtual model of a
physical piece of paper,
the natural thing to do
is build a physical model
of the virtual model of the
physical piece of paper.
And you've seen this
on the mailing list.
This is what we're
calling origami skeletons.
Here the vertices, which
you can see bigger here,
are 3D printed plastic spheres,
and there's aluminum rods.
The spheres have holes
at just the right angles
to make exactly the 3D form
that was made by that simulator.
So this is something you
could really only build
if you had a virtual
model of that thing.
So this is a fun example
of taking mathematics
and our sort of the
computational understanding
of how paper folds
and turning it
into sculpture that requires
that mathematical basis.
On the topic of sculpture,
at the very beginning--
so this is early on in my PhD,
with my dad and my PhD advisor
Anna Lubiw, same authors as
like the folding problem,
one of our early explorations on
the mathematical sculpture side
was to take
hyperbolic paraboloids
and take a lot of them
and join them together
to make polyhedral surfaces.
These are what we
call hyperhedra
because hyperbolic paraboloids
are also called hypars,
I think, originally by
the architect community.
So these are
algorithmically-generated
sculpture.
The input to the algorithm is
a polyhedron, like the cube,
and the output is a way
to join hypars together
to represent that cube.
And the algorithm
is very simple.
For each face of the
polyhedron-- so here it
has four sides, you take
four hyperbolic paraboloids
and join them together in a
cycle just sharing one edge.
So you do that for each of
the six faces, so in all
you have 24 hyperbolic
paraboloids.
Then to join two
faces together, you
join them along a pair
of edges like this.
And when you do that,
you get an enclosure.
It's a closed solid.
And you can do that
for every-- here
we're doing it for all
the Platonic solids.
You can do it with any
polyhedron in theory.
So it's like an infinite
family of sculptures here,
which is kind of fun.
Here is a simulation of
that cube just for fun.
That works, too.
And back to the curve creases.
These are some examples I
showed way back in lecture 1.
These are sculptures in the
permanent collection at MOMA.
And the idea here
is instead of taking
just one concentric circle
which goes around 360 degrees,
we take a circular ramp
which goes around twice,
and then join the ends.
So we have 720
degrees of material
there, which you might think
of as negative curvature.
But it's a little
weird because there's
the hole cut out in the center.
So it's a little hard
to measure curvature,
but you can actually define it.
And these are three
different foldings
with the same idea, slightly
different parameters
in how big those ramps are, and
different numbers of creases.
And you get very different
equilibrium forms.
Again, this all sort
of self-folding paper
wants to live in these
three configurations.
Here's some that you
may not have seen.
They're on the web.
But these are taking
regular 360-degree circles
but taking two or
three or four of them
and joining them at a
couple of key points,
and the rest is self-folding.
So the big-- I mean, the sort of
powerful scientific engineering
idea here is that you
could deploy complicated
3D structures just
by manufacturing
very simple flat
structures, maybe
joining a few points together,
and then just say go.
If you can manufacture
these things
so that every crease
locally wants to bend,
then you'll get these
3D forms automatically.
This is especially powerful
at the nano scale, where
you can't have your fingers
moving around and pressing
things.
But you can probably
use materials
that, say, when heated
or you add some chemical,
cause everything to fold.
It's very easy for us from
all the chip fabrication
we do to manufacture
flat crease patterns,
and that will let us manufacture
3D things at the nano scale.
You could also imagine it a
much larger scale like a space
station-- like a space
station that looks like that.
That would be pretty
cool-- and something
where you don't want
to have to physically
fold everything by hand.
But if it could be
done automatically,
life would be good.
Now, we don't have
any algorithms
for the reverse
engineering problem--
If I give you a 3D
curved surface like this,
find the crease pattern and
the joins that make it happen.
But that's the goal.
And towards that goal,
we make sculpture
to explore the space
of what you can make.
All right.
I think I have one more
sculptural example here,
which is combining these curve
creases with glassblowing.
And to make glassblowing
more tactical,
Marty here, our cameraman,
is blowing glass blindfold.
Don't try this at home.
So paper folding is a
very tactile experience.
To make glassblowing more about
touching the material, which
you're not usually supposed
to do because it's over 1,000
degrees Fahrenheit-- blindfolds.
AUDIENCE: 1,000
degrees Centigrade.
PROFESSOR: 1,000
degrees centigrade.
Wow.
The temperature of
an erupting volcano.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is in the glassblowing
studio in 4.003 near here.
He's made a whole
bunch of those.
And here's what it looks like to
fold from scratch, so to speak,
a concentric circle model.
Of course, it's
accelerated in movie time.
It only takes 10 seconds.
In reality, it takes 10 minutes
after pre-scoring, maybe more.
And now we get some
ship-in-the-bottle action.
And this is a lot of fun
for us because not only
do you have the
self-folding constraint,
but you have this
enclosure constraint.
These forms would
not look as exciting
if they could
sprawl out, and they
didn't have any constraints
to live inside these bubbles.
So you get yet
another collection
of forms from that glass.
All right.
I think that's the end of
our little sculpture tour.
We'll come back to sculpture
at the end of this lecture.
But I want to talk more
about-- oh, question.
AUDIENCE: What was the
idea behind the blindfold?
PROFESSOR: What was the
So paper folding is all
about touching material.
Glassblowing is
usually very visual.
It's about you look
at the material,
and you don't usually touch it.
So we wanted to unify the two
in order to put them together.
Plus it was just a crazy idea.
I think what happened
is I was in my office.
My dad calls me up.
He's blowing glass.
He's like, I got
this great idea.
Come over with a camera.
So in that video, I
was the cameraman.
And I was like,
all right, you want
to burn yourself blowing glass.
He didn't actually burn himself.
Usually, he does.
But blindfold, he
was more careful.
Yeah, blindfold glassblowing,
it's pretty crazy.
That was his first
try ever blindfold
glassblowing in that video.
All right.
So this hyperbolic
paraboloid, it's
been around for a long time.
I didn't mention the history.
It goes back to the
Bauhaus in the late '20s.
Albers, who I'm sure
many of you know of,
taught a class about design.
And he liked using
paper as a material that
would force you to focus--
not worry about material
in the sort of architectural
scale and what would stand up--
and just think about design.
And paper folding was really
tactile and good for that.
And I'm not sure exactly
whether it was him
or a student of his, it's
somebody in that period, 1927,
'28, came up with this
model and the circular one.
And then it's been taught
many times since then.
Then it really hit it big in the
origami community in the 1980s
by [INAUDIBLE], and since then
everybody's been folding it.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is it not rigid,
but paper [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Ah, you made one.
Can I show it?
Thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
Simple little example, but
here is concentric squares,
and you crease it down.
Normally you get this
kind of X. You let go,
and it pops into
a little saddle.
So this is a sort of
low-resolution one.
If you spend twice
as much time, you
can double the
resolution and so on.
Your question, is it rigid?
Probably not rigid.
There's like this
degree of freedom.
AUDIENCE: Rigid in
the sense of that
between creases [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What's happening in
between the creases?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
PROFESSOR: That is exactly
the topic of today's lecture.
In fact, we have a paper called
"How Does Paper Fold Between
Creases" to address
exactly this question.
I'm going to hang
onto it, if you
don't mind because it'll
be useful to point at.
In fact, it is
completely impossible
to fold that crease
pattern into this shape.
And so your idea that there's
something weird going on
is an idea-- we've
known for a long time
that these faces
could not stay planar.
I mean, at least visually it's
hard to see unless you stare
at it with all the right angles.
But the faces look
like they twist.
Now, that's OK.
Paper can do all sorts of
curving stuff without creasing.
I mean, this is sort of like
a twist, no creases involved.
So we thought this was
possible, but in fact, it's not.
So this is the big surprise.
It's something we
discovered just last year,
and I'm going to prove
that to you today.
So the theorem is, if I have
this concentric square crease
pattern, even ignoring
the mountains and valleys,
it is impossible to
fold that crease pattern
into anything that is not flat.
So you can, of course,
not fold it at all,
then none of the
creases get folded.
You can collapse it
all the way down.
That probably
isn't even allowed.
But never mind.
But what we really
want is a 3D form
where every crease is
bent by a non-zero angle
and also not by 180 degrees.
So we'll call that a
proper folding, something
where every crease is
strictly between 0 and 180,
which is what we want
in these 3D forms.
And the theorem is,
that is impossible
for the hyperbolic paraboloid.
There is none.
So that's weird because
we fold them all the time.
We've been folding
them for like 11 years,
and other people have been
folding them for 80 years.
What's happening with
the real piece of paper?
Well, one possible answer
is that there's more creases
that you don't
see in this model.
And if you add
more creases, it is
possible to fold
something that looks
like a hyperbolic paraboloid.
So here we have the regular
crease pattern in black,
and then I've added
some purple diagonals.
Wherever we had a
black trapezoid,
I've added one purple
diagonal to triangulate
the crease pattern.
And here I've chosen what
seems to be an especially
good triangulation
where I zigzag
back and forth
within one quarter.
And then also from around a
ring, I zigzag back and forth.
So that triangulation
folds into this.
That's another theorem.
This is construction on a
computer, obviously, where
we have 16 rings, and
the central crease here
is folded by an
angle of 30 degrees.
That's the theta.
Notice I also had to
remove part of a diagonal.
That's also necessary.
In the center, you
can't crease both
of those, the folds in an
X, by a non-zero amount.
Those are all things we're
going to prove today.
But before we prove
the negative things,
I want to prove
the positive thing,
that this thing can
actually be built.
That may seem obvious
because here it is.
I built one.
But because there's all these
arguments of, well, here it
is, I built one, we've got to
be especially careful about,
does this thing
really truly exist?
So let me tell you
how it's constructed
and how we can actually prove
not only can we build it
approximately on a computer,
but we can prove there really
is one there even though
we don't have it exactly.
So it's actually pretty
cool and pretty easy.
So this is the triangulated
hyperbolic paraboloid.
So the idea is to work
from the inside out.
We're going to start
with this central square
here-- and let me draw
it over here-- fold it
by some angle theta.
That, I think, we
all know how to do.
It's some rotation matrix.
And then I want to
work my way out.
So at this point,
I know the location
of these four vertices.
In general, I know some
square and everything inside.
I want to figure out
everything in the next square.
And the creases are going to
look like this, from my zigzag
pattern.
So there's stuff in
here, which is known.
So I already have figured out
the location of these vertices.
And I want to know,
how do I figure out
these vertices on the outside?
If I can do that, I just repeat,
and I get a bigger and bigger
hyperbolic paraboloid.
So what I do is pretty easy.
I'm going to look at this
vertex first and say,
well, I have these
three points, and I
have known distances
between those three points.
I'm going to assume here,
and we'll see why later,
that each of these
creases remains
a straight line in
three dimensions.
It's not obvious, because
creases might bend around.
But let's assume
that we were going
to fold it in a simple way.
These triangles are going
to remain triangles.
These edges will
remain straight.
And they have to
remain the same length
because we're paper folding.
You can't stretch.
And so I know these
three points in 3D,
and I know these
three distances, just
measuring them on the crease
pattern, flat crease pattern.
So this point is on the
intersection of three spheres,
and the centers of the
spheres are not collinear.
This is a trick we used last
class but in two dimensions.
So I have three
non-collinear points.
I have three spheres--
little hard to draw--
centered at them.
The intersection of
two of the spheres
is going to be a circle,
and the intersection
with the third sphere is going
to be actually two points.
So the intersection of
three spheres is two points.
So a little bit of ambiguity.
But it turns out
one of these points
will set the mountain-valley
assignment correctly,
and the other one will
set it incorrectly.
Like if I want this to be
a mountain, one of them
will be inside and one
of them will be outside.
One of them will
make this mountain,
one will make it valley.
So it turns out if
you actually do this,
it's uniquely determined
at every step of the way.
Because you know what
mountain-valley assignment
you're aiming for, you uniquely
figure out what this point is.
By the same reasoning,
you can figure out
what this point is, intersect
these three spheres.
And then once I know
those two points,
I can figure out this
point because it's
the intersection of
these three spheres,
with now these points are known.
And then I can figure out this
point in the symmetric way.
OK?
That's how you do it.
We repeat.
And that is exactly how
this model is built.
Now, this is still not a
proof that it really folds.
It's a construction method.
I'd say it's an algorithm.
If I start out with
the inner thing here
and I give you some angle,
I can approximate where
these vertices are.
And then I can keep going
and, at each step of the way,
approximate where
the vertices are.
The worry is the approximation
gets worse and worse because I
have this propagating
error effect.
The larger n is,
the number of rings
in my hyperbolic paraboloid,
the lower the accuracy will be.
But I get to
choose, at each step
of the way, how
much precision I use
to compute all of these numbers.
Let me tell you how this
computation actually works.
I did this in Mathematica, or
we did this in Mathematica.
Here's Mathematica.
And I asked
Mathematica, well, here
is the equations for the
intersection of three spheres.
I say, well, squared Euclidean
distance between this point
and some unknown thing x, y,
z is this distance squared.
And here's the second one,
and here's the third one.
It's kind of tiny.
And then here's the answer.
It's a little messy.
In fact, you can ask how
many terms are in this thing.
It's 444,000 terms
in the solution.
Don't try this at
home, I guess, by hand.
Intersection of three
spheres is a bit messy.
There's probably a cleaner way
than what Mathematica does,
but this is an easy
way to get it in.
Now, in theory-- so if you
look at all of this stuff,
all that's happening
is you have all
the various inputs, x1,
y1, x2, z2, and so on.
You have some numbers
like 4 and minus and 2.
All you're doing is
taking these numbers,
adding them, multiplying them,
dividing them, squaring them,
subtracting them.
And at some point,
taking square roots.
I don't know if
we'll ever see that.
I mean, if we search through,
there are some square roots,
but they're going to be
in very specific places.
Yeah, so I probably
won't find one instantly.
Oh, there's one, square root.
So all I'm claiming
at this point
is you can compute the
intersection of three
spheres just using basic
arithmetic and square roots.
This is called a
radical expression,
not because it's so
amazing and controversial.
But it's radical because that
symbol is called rad, I guess,
and radical refers
to square roots.
I guess they were
crazy at the time.
All right.
Actually, I want to
stay with Mathematica.
So that's the idea.
Still not a proof, just
a construction method.
But here's a trick,
which you can
use to turn a construction
into an actual proof
that this thing exists.
It's called interval arithmetic,
little computer science lesson.
How many people have heard
of interval arithmetic?
No one-- one person, all right.
Yeah, even computer scientists
probably don't necessarily
know this unless they've
seen some numerical analysis.
So it's an idea that
instead of computing
an approximate location
for this point,
I want to get not only an
approximate location, but also
an error bound on how
much I don't know it.
So there are three
coordinates to every point.
For each coordinate, every
number I want to represent I'm
going to represent
as an interval
from some lower bound
to some upper bound.
So say, well, I don't
know what the value is,
but I know that it is somewhere
in between these two numbers.
So represent every
number like this.
And then you just need
to define, how do I
add numbers, subtract them,
multiply them, divide them,
and take square roots?
And the answer is carefully.
I'll show you one example.
If I have two numbers,
L1, U1, and L2, U2,
and I want to add
them together, then I
believe it's pretty simple.
It's just L1 plus
L2, and U1 plus U2.
This is in perfect
mathematical world
where there's no round off.
In reality, when
you add two numbers,
you lose a bit of precision.
And you make sure that
when you add these numbers,
you always round down, and
when you add these numbers
you always round up.
So that way, these intervals,
the accumulation error
is realized by these
intervals getting wider.
You can start with
them super tiny,
maybe, in fact, 0
length because you
know exactly where these points
are, so they're 0 intervals.
But then, because of the
error in every operation
you do on the computer,
the intervals will widen.
But as long as you
do this computation
with enough bits of precision,
they'll widen slowly.
If you do it slowly
enough-- if you do it
with enough precision, and
the errors accumulate slowly
enough, you can build your
n-ring hyperbolic paraboloid
without any error, or
without too much error
to make things go wrong.
What could go wrong is that
these three spheres might not
intersect.
That's really the worry here.
There are two things
that could go wrong.
One is that the spheres
don't intersect.
The other is that the
surface intersects itself.
Both would be bad.
How do you tell when the
spheres don't intersect?
Well, we have this formula,
this ginormous formula.
The only thing
that could go wrong
is that you take a square
root of a negative number.
Now, hopefully that
never happens in reality.
But what could
happen for us is we
have such a poor
approximation of our numbers.
And we try to take the
square root of some interval,
and L is less than 0.
Now, probably the actual
number is more than 0,
but we can't tell,
and we just know
the number is somewhere
in this interval.
If the lower bound
is negative, then we
can't take the square root.
We don't know what the
right answer would be.
So Mathematica conveniently
can do all of this for you.
If you just plug in
intervals instead of numbers,
it will do interval
arithmetic correctly,
and you can tell it
what precision to do.
And that is how we
found this example.
In fact, I will show
you the notebook,
and there's all this
computation and stuff.
This is all, I believe,
it's in our paper,
so if you want the code.
So we compute the
crease patterns
so I can measure
all the distances.
And there's some collision
detection and stuff
to make sure
everything's working.
And it computes some rings.
And then, actually, the one I
want to show you is this one.
This is model we've
been looking at,
and here it is in
three dimensions.
The way it's being rendered is
a bit odd, but you get the idea.
That is the hyperbolic
paraboloid we construct.
Now, in reality,
each of these points
is actually a little interval.
It's hard to draw
that because it's
smaller than the
resolution of the screen.
I think I compute
up here the-- this
is like how much we've
messed up the edge lengths.
It's like all of
these 9's, and then
this little area at the end.
OK.
Cool.
So the point is, you just do
this with enough precision.
As long as you don't
end up computing
any negative square
roots, you get a surface
where every point is
actually a little box.
You don't know where the
point is exactly in that box.
Then you check for
collision, just knowing
that the points are
somewhere in those boxes.
You try to intersect
two triangles.
As long as they intersect away
from the boxes, you're OK.
Then you know there's
no actual intersection.
And we have done that
for this triangulation up
to-- get it right--
up to n equals
100, 100 rings, and where
the theta angle here
is any even number between 2
and 178 degrees, so 2 degrees,
4 degrees, up to 178 degrees.
We're not interested in 180
because that would be flat.
That's not interesting.
We're not interested in 0.
Every even number of
degrees in between.
Why even?
Just because of
the representation.
I'm sure it works for the odd.
In fact, I'm pretty
sure it should
work for any theta and any n.
But this technique will
only let us to prove it
for specific theta
and specific n.
Because we're just
using a computer,
it's only going to
check one example.
We don't have a nice way
to do them all at once.
In case you're
interested-- oh, here I've
built it out of sheet
aluminum, I think?
AUDIENCE: Galvanized--
PROFESSOR: Galvanized steel?
All right.
Water jet cut along the creases.
Now, steel's a little tricky
to not add extra pieces
by accident, so
there's a few defects.
But this is also some kind of
verification that it works.
In the computer here, the
number of digits of precision.
So for whatever
reason, Mathematica
speaks base 10
instead of base 2.
Which is weird to me, but maybe
intuitive to everyone else,
non-computer scientist, I guess.
So there's normal sort
of floating points
like 16 digits of
precision or so.
And there you can build this
thing up to n equals 3, 3
rings.
But you go up to about
1,000 digits of precision,
and then we can get beyond 100.
It depends, though, on what
the angle is that you fold.
So for angles that are
very big, close to 90,
we had to go up to 2,000
digits of precision.
And I don't know how
far n can go here.
I think maybe a couple 100,
but I'm not sure exactly.
The larger n is, of course,
the more accumulation you have,
and so you have to
do every operation
with more digits of precision.
But the conjecture would be,
any specific data and n, there's
some precision for which
this approach will work,
but we don't actually
know how to prove that.
All right.
So that's a triangulated hypar.
Here's another
triangulation, which we also
studied in this paper, where
instead of zigzagging up
one quarter of the
square, we just
do all the diagonals
in the same direction.
We still zigzag around a
ring but not between rings.
And this can also fold,
as the other model
that was in the
Mathematica file.
I won't bother going there.
This is for a small fold angle
of just 8 degrees in here,
n equals 16.
And there's a reason I
did it for a small angle,
because it doesn't
work for large angles.
So that triangulation we
started with was a good one.
It's actually not the
first one we tried,
but it is sort of natural.
If you fold by a
very small amount,
you can get all the
way up to 133 rings,
but then it fails after that.
The spheres just don't
intersect anymore.
Depending on how much you fold,
like if I fold by 22 degrees,
I can get up to 13 rings.
But here I wanted
to get to 16 rings
so I only went up to, what was
it, 8 degrees or something.
I could have gotten a
little beyond but not a lot.
And up at 178, you can
still get three rings,
but it doesn't fold after that.
So triangulation matters,
which triangulation you do.
Going back to the
one that works well,
natural question
is, is it actually
a hyperbolic paraboloid?
It's called a hyperbolic
paraboloid because--
or there is a surface called
a hyperbolic paraboloid, where
if you take a cross-section
this way, you get a parabola.
That's the paraboloid part.
And if you take a cross-section
this way, you get a hyperbola.
That's a little
harder to draw, but it
goes around here
and around here.
Hyperbolas have two
connecting components.
So let's look at the
parabolic part here.
We're supposed to be
approximating a parabola if we
look at all the points on
the top here and also maybe
on the bottom.
So that's what I've drawn.
The green lines, which
are very light so a little
tricky to see, they
zigzag back and forth,
and that is what we compute.
Again, it's approximate, but
it's so close to accurate
that I just draw them
as single points.
The error is much smaller than
the thickness of these lines.
And then the blue
and purple lines
here are fits of
the best parabola
that matches these points.
Actually, it's not
even the best parabola.
It's kind of funny.
I just take the last three
points-- three points
determine a parabola.
I take the parabola that
fits through those three
points and bam!
It is almost a perfect fit.
These are the error
charts, I guess.
This is relative errors,
probably the most informative.
Or actually, it's the ratio--
it's not really an error--
the fit value over
the actual value.
So when it's 1, that
means it's perfect.
And yeah, this is at the end
of the chain where I fit it,
so of course it's going
to be perfect out here.
At the center, at
the very beginning--
so I'm only looking at one
quarter of this thing-- yeah,
the error is a little bit.
The ratio is not 1,
but it's 0.9997 or so,
maybe a little bit less, so
that I had to write it down.
It's like 0.003% error,
if I got it right,
maybe just 0.03% error.
Fix the notes.
Something like that.
It's very small is the point.
But it is non-zero.
I mean, initially
we thought, well,
maybe if you increase
the resolution-- you
make a finer and finer
hyperbolic paraboloid--
it will more closely approximate
a hyperbolic paraboloid.
That does not seem to
be true because, really,
making it finer is really
just like making it bigger.
You never really change
the center behavior.
It's always the same.
And this construction proves it.
We build the center, and we
can go as far out as we want.
It's just changing the
scale of the thing.
But the center will
always remain the same,
and it will always
remain off the parabola,
but super, super close.
Really, it's all right to call
this a hyperbolic paraboloid,
but you should
triangulate, especially
if you're making something
out of more rigid material.
Cool.
Let's go on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Do the creases
have to be uniform?
I mean, could you
tighten up inside?
PROFESSOR: The creases do
not have to be uniform.
Most of the hyperbolic
paraboloids we've made,
we do evenly space
all the squares,
but they don't have to be.
I say that in that we've
made them out of paper,
and they fold to
something, and you
get other kinds of surfaces.
Probably not going to be a
hyperbolic paraboloid anymore.
I have not done it
with Mathematica
and checked that it really is
possible, but it should be.
That would be a fun thing
to explore at some point.
Other questions?
All right.
So this is the end
of the positive news
for hyperbolic paraboloids.
Now we're going to go
to the negative stuff,
showing that it is
impossible to fold
this with this crease pattern.
Hyperbolic paraboloids don't
exist without triangulation.
For this we need a
little bit of math tools
in this paper, "How Paper
Folds Between Creases."
So in the study
that we just did,
I assumed that all of the
creases stayed straight.
And therefore that all
of the faces-- therefore?
Yeah, I guess, because
triangles are rigid.
If I forced the edges of the
triangle to stay straight,
then the interior
of the triangle
must stay flat just
to preserve distances.
So I assumed that every face of
the piece of paper stayed flat.
Why did I assume that?
Because paper, real
paper, does not
have to stay flat in
between the creases.
This is real stuff here.
But paper is constrained on how
it can curve without creases,
and that is the purpose of this
little mathematical endeavour.
There's some technical stuff,
and I want to get to the meat
as quickly as possible.
But I'll just mention
some assumptions.
We assume that the
thing that we fold,
the folding of our piece
of paper, is piecewise C2.
C2 means you can
take two derivatives,
and it's still good and
continuous and sort of smooth
up to the second level.
Piecewise means, of
course, we have creases.
Those are not C2, not even C1.
So we have some crease
pattern on our piece of paper.
It's whatever.
And what we mean is that inside
one of these regions, it's C2.
On the creases, it's nothing.
It's C0.
It's continuous.
We don't rip the paper.
But we don't necessarily
have derivatives everywhere.
So that's the assumption.
Now, one annoying
thing here is you
can have something called
a semi-crease, something
we call a semi-crease,
which is C1 but not C2.
Yeah.
So you have to
divide into pieces,
but it's not
technically a crease.
And this is some of the worry
of what might be happening.
Maybe you don't
need creases here,
you only need semi-creases.
Maybe you only need to violate
the second derivative, not
the first.
Creases should be violation
of first derivative.
Those are sharp things.
Semi-creases are just
kind of little sharp.
It's like-- what's a good
example of a semi-sharp thing?
I guess if I take a
parabola, and then
I take a more shallow
parabola, then at this point
there's no second derivative
because the first derivatives
don't meet.
This one has a first
derivative of this.
derivative of that.
They're not the same.
Is that true?
Parabolas maybe not.
But you get the idea.
This is a discontinuity
in the second derivative,
not the first.
All right.
I'm going to basically
ignore semi-creases here,
though, because they're
just kind of a technicality.
They don't end up mattering.
So we have piecewise C2.
And we assume that our
surface is intrinsically flat,
meaning it came from a
piece of paper-- trinsic--
oh, boy, intrinsically flat.
Now this is something we
know as curvature zero.
And I want to tell you a little
bit more about curvature.
We have defined curvature
in a few different-- well,
I guess in one
particular way, which
is you add up the material,
and you take 360 minus that.
So curvature zero
means you have 360
of material, which is good news.
But there are other
ways to define it,
in particular, the
way Gauss defined it.
This is usually called
Gaussian curvature
because he invented it.
Gauss defined curvature
of a 3D surface.
You have some weird
curved 3D thing,
like this shape,
the orange part.
And there's actually a lot of
natural notions of curvature
here.
Gaussian curvature
is just one of them.
So let me tell you a
little bit about that.
We're looking at
this point, and I
want to compute the
curvature of this point.
Well, if I look
in any direction,
like say this red
direction-- so it's
like I slice this world with
a plane, this blue plane,
I get a nice
one-dimensional curve.
Then the curvature is how bent
that curve is at that point.
That's like a
directional curvature.
In this direction, how bent
is-- what does how bent mean?
It just means you try to
nestle a circle in there,
in that plane, and you
take 1 over the radius.
That's a curvature.
OK?
So if it's flat, the radius
could be infinite, and so
curvature zero.
If it's very sharp, then
the radius is very small.
And so 1 over the radius is
very large, big curvature.
So it's some thing here.
Let's say it's a
positive number.
And then if I take, for example,
this other blue plane, so
this cross-section,
in that direction
the curvature is
bent the other way.
So you say, well, there
the directional curvature
is negative.
It depends which way is up.
One of them is positive,
one of them is negative.
Somewhere in between
it's going to be 0.
But you have all these different
directional curvatures.
The Gaussian curvature,
which is the one
that we sort of know and love
and have used a lot, mostly
for polyhedra, is the
min directional curvature
times the max
directional curvature.
Now, I really mean min and max.
So the smallest one, in
this case, is negative.
The largest one is positive.
You take the product, and
that's the Gaussian curvature.
It's a weird thing.
But in particular,
because there's
a negative one and
a positive one here,
that means the
product is negative,
and that's because
this is a saddle.
Still the case, negative
Gaussian curvature
means saddle.
Positive means a convex cone.
0 means intrinsically flat.
So this is still
the thing we know,
but this is a weird way
of thinking about it.
This is how Gauss defined it.
And he proved that even
if you fold the surface,
the Gaussian curvature
never changes.
That is called the
theorema egregium.
Cool name.
So Gaussian curvature
doesn't change under folding.
We start with something
that's flat, zero curvature.
Because if you
take a flat plane,
you take any directional
curvature, everything's 0.
So it's the product
of min and mix.
They're both 0.
So we start with something zero
curvature, it will remain so.
Now, if I have a
product of two things,
and I know this is
equal to 0, that
means one of the two
things is 0, maybe both.
If it's still a plane,
both of them will be 0.
But one of them
still has to be 0.
What this means is, basically,
locally at any point,
we have a cylinder, some
kind of generalized cylinder.
But it really only
curves in one direction
because there's some direction
where it doesn't curve at all.
Everything's straight.
In all the other
directions, yeah, it
curves different amounts.
The orthogonal direction will
be where it curves the most.
That will be the max, I
guess, and the min will be 0.
So that is what a
folded sheet looks like.
And it's maybe not
so obvious, but when
I did all this
contorting and what not,
really I was only bending in
one dimension, like a cylinder.
That's not exactly
a cylinder because I
can change the radius of the
cylinder all over the place,
but I'm really only
bending in one direction.
I was reading on Wikipedia,
this explains how we eat pizza.
Because you take
a piece of pizza,
which is basically
like a piece of paper,
and if you bend it a little
bit, like you push in the center
and push up on the
sides, you give it
some curvature in one direction.
And therefore it has to
remain straight in the other,
so it kind of supports
the piece of pizza.
Never thought of it
that way, but there you
go, practical applications
for this stuff.
All right.
These things we
call planar points.
If I have a point p and it's
locally flat like a plane,
call it planar.
These things, for some crazy
reason, we call parabolic.
This is to be consistent
with other notation.
I know it looks-- cylindrical
would be another fine term.
But there's a third
kind called a elliptic,
which would be like this stuff.
That doesn't happen.
So we just worry about
locally cylinder, which
we're going to call parabolic
because it's also like locally
a parabola, doesn't
matter, and locally planar.
Those are the two kinds
of points we can have.
Now, I'm going to give you some
accelerated facts we're just
going to take as given
from differential geometry.
Well, really, we had
to take some facts that
were about differential
geometry and sort of port
them to our context.
They didn't give us
exactly what we wanted.
We had to generalize
them a little.
Differential geometry, if you
were at Sunday's lectures,
that was one of the main
tools being used there.
Differential geometry is about
smooth things, like C4 usually.
Now, sometimes about C2 things.
It is almost never about
piecewise C2 things.
So you got to worry
about the pieces.
Now, most the time,
we're thinking
about one little region
here, and that's nice in C2.
And you can check.
Most of the differential
geometry still applies there.
Blah, blah, blah.
Let me tell you some facts.
If I take a smooth point, so
that means not on a crease
and not a semi-crease,
then it lies on something
called a rule segment,
which is a line segment,
also called a rule line.
And the endpoints
of that segment,
here's the interesting part,
are on creases or the boundary.
So we already know
from this picture
that any point
lies on a segment,
like an actual 3D
line segment, because
of this parabolic nature.
What's interesting is that
segment, it can't stop.
Just keeps on going,
like the Energizer bunny,
until it hits a crease.
At that point,
things aren't smooth.
We don't know what happens.
But really, these
creases go straight.
Those are rule lines.
And here, actually, we have
a choice, many different rule
lines.
But in the parabolic case,
that rule line is unique.
It's going to be unique
for parabolic points.
And so we get what's called a
ruled surface, which is just
the union of a whole bunch
of line segments, rule lines,
around any point.
Maybe any smooth
point, just to be safe.
So you may have heard
of ruled surfaces.
They're quite common.
They're fun because you can
build them out of strings.
So each string, if you hold
taut, it's a line segment.
Take a whole bunch of them
and just imagine the envelope
there.
That is a 3D surface, and
that's a ruled surface.
Now this one does not
have zero curvature.
It has negative
curvature everywhere.
So that can't happen.
This actually can happen.
This is like you take
a helix, and so there's
a blue curve in
3D, a space curve.
And then you imagine taking
the tangent at every point.
So just like if you just went
straight at every point instead
of turning, then you
get a bunch of lines.
Those are rule lines.
And you get this cool surface.
Now, that is a valid
folding of a piece of paper.
Doesn't look like a
cylinder, does it?
But locally, each of these
lines looks like a cylinder.
It's just the radius
of the cylinder
is changing all over the place.
But that's a valid folding
of a piece of paper, I think.
Has zero curvature
everywhere, if I did it right.
Or I didn't do it, but if
I imagine it correctly.
All right.
So it's a ruled surface, great.
I mean, I can really create
my whole surface locally
around a point by a whole
bunch of rule segments.
They're not all going to be
parallel or anything, which
is what we imagined
from the cylinder.
They can turn around.
But these segments do keep going
until they hit another crease.
Maybe the blue line's a crease.
And the boundary here could
be the boundary of the paper,
could be a crease boundary.
But that's what they look like.
Now, it's also what we
call torsal, torsal ruled.
Here we get to somewhat
more obscure terminology
but some useful things.
It's quite restricted.
I want to have a common
tangent plane throughout a rule
segment.
So if I look at any one
of these rule segments,
there's one plane,
which is going
to be like this, that is tangent
to the surface at every point
along that segment.
So in general, you might
imagine that the tangent
plane turns as we go along.
But these segments are kind of--
they're locally cylindrical.
So you can really make a
tangent plane all the way along.
Whereas here, that's
probably not true.
Imagine the tangent plane
starts-- can you see my hand?
It starts to bend
like this, and it's
going to bend around like that.
It twists along a single line.
In our case where we
have zero curvature,
it's actually going
to be torsal ruled,
meaning the tangent plane
just goes straight along each
of these lines.
We're going to need this,
that's why I mention it.
Another fun fact
along the same spirit
is that the points
along a rule line
are all the same in
terms of whether they
are planar or parabolic.
So I'll call them uniformly
planar slash parabolic.
Remember, planar just
means it lies in a plane.
Parabolic is the other case.
So here everything's parabolic.
But you can't like suddenly
switch in the middle
and become flat.
That's not allowed,
not possible.
So those are some fun facts.
We're not going to prove them.
If you want to see the proofs,
they're a bit technical.
You have to read our paper, and
then the differential geometry
books we cite.
But a bunch of these things, you
can understand the proofs just
assuming a little bit of
differential geometry,
and it's not too hard.
It's in our paper, but it's
a little bit technical.
So I want to look at the
things that are more related
to paper folding,
how paper folds.
This is obviously
related, but it's
like the foundation on which
we build what I care about.
What I care about
most-- all right,
let me tell you a fun fact,
what we're going to prove.
We want this nice proper folding
of the hyperbolic paraboloid,
meaning every crease is bent
by a non-zero angle and not 180
degrees.
In that situation,
first claim is
every crease remains straight.
Second claim is every
face remains rigid,
can't bend anywhere--
every interior face.
These guys on the boundary,
they can do crazy things.
And you see that
in the model, where
the outside gets
kind of all wiggly.
That's allowed.
The outside faces,
the ones that share
the boundary with the paper,
can wiggle, can curve.
But everything else
has to remain flat
if there are no
creases in there.
And that's not at all obvious.
So we're going to prove it.
And I need some water.
All right.
First claim, I'll call it
polygonal implies flat.
So what I mean is, suppose
I have some region of paper.
It's in the middle somewhere.
Let's say it's smooth.
And I look at the
boundary of the region.
Doesn't actually
have to be smooth.
It could have semi-creases.
But it has no creases inside.
Suppose the boundary
in 3D is a polygon,
so it's piecewise straight.
I don't know how that
corresponds to anything,
but say the boundary
is straight.
Then the inside must be planar.
So if I have a
polygonal boundary,
then I have a flat
planar inside.
This is assuming no creases.
OK?
So what that means is that
every point inside this region
must be planar, not parabolic.
That's what we want to prove.
So let's do a proof
by contradiction,
and suppose that we
have a parabolic point.
So we have some point,
and locally it is curved,
and we know there's a
rule line through it.
I know by smoothness,
by continuity,
that if this guy is parabolic,
it's bent, then, in fact,
all the points nearby
should also be bent,
because you can't go instantly
from bent to straight.
You've got to do that slowly.
So there's some
little region-- we
call this a neighborhood--
around the point that
is all parabolic.
So I'll call this
parabolic neighborhood.
All right.
All of those points
have unique rule lines.
That's what we've been saying.
So I take this
little neighborhood,
and each one of them
defines some rule line.
Those rule lines
go all the way out
to the boundary
something like this.
Now, this boundary
is the boundary.
That means it's polygonal,
can't be curved like this.
In fact, it looks
something like this.
Maybe this is straight.
Maybe this has two segments.
We don't know how many segments.
I just want to look at
one of these segments here
and all the rule lines
coming out of it.
So what I have is I have
the boundary of the paper.
That's a poor imitation
of a straight line.
Straight line.
I have some rule
lines coming out.
Now, I don't really know
what they look like.
I want to understand
This is in 3D.
Imagine.
OK, this is straight.
First thing I want to look at
is the normal to the surface.
So normal is like
perpendicular to the surface.
It's easy to define normals in
the interior of the surface,
but I can actually extend
that out to the boundary.
So I want to look
at a normal here.
Maybe let me put it here,
something like that.
If I took normals really
close to the boundary,
I just took the limit
out to the boundary,
I'll get some normal vector.
And by smoothness, that exists.
Just wave my hands
there, but that's true.
OK, what's true
about this normal?
Well, it's perpendicular
to the surface.
Now locally, the
surface here, it's
defined by the plane of this
line segment and this line
segment.
So in fact, it's
perpendicular to the boundary,
and it's perpendicular
here to the rule line.
Buy that?
If I take some other normal,
like this one-- sorry,
like that, it's also
perpendicular to this,
but it's perpendicular to
some other rule line now.
So these guys are
perpendicular to a common line,
but they may not be
the same direction.
What we do know, though,
is that it's torsal.
There is a single
tangent plane that's
perpendicular to this
entire rule line, which
means the normal is
the thing perpendicular
to that tangent plane.
So in fact, all of the
normals along this line
are identical, which
is kind of neat.
These guys are all parallel.
Same thing here.
I won't draw that.
It's going to get too messy.
So what?
All right.
Well, here's a crazy
thing to imagine.
I will look at the
derivative of the normal.
So I have this point p.
Imagine you have a point p, and
it's moving along this curve
continuously.
Sorry-- not curve.
This is a straight line.
It's moving along this edge
of the boundary just once.
It goes like this.
And I'm going to define n of
p is the normal at that point.
So it starts at something,
and then maybe it's changing.
I get to this normal,
then I get to this normal,
and then who knows
what it looks like.
I want to understand,
can it change at all?
So to understand its
change, I'm going
to take the derivative,
n prime of p.
So this is as p
moves along here,
how does the normal change?
I claim, in fact, it
can't change at all.
Why?
Well, the derivative of
the normal, first of all,
must be perpendicular to-- I
haven't given anything a name
here.
This thing is the boundary edge.
So here's my boundary edge.
Every single normal here--
I didn't draw the greatest
picture-- of those have to
be perpendicular to this one
common edge.
Here's the fact where we use
that this is a straight line.
If it curves, then this
is not a consistent thing.
But because it's straight for
a while, all of these guys
are perpendicular
to the same thing.
All of the ends are
perpendicular to the boundary
edge.
This is just little
perpendicular notation.
And if all of the n's are
perpendicular to the boundary
edge, the change in n must
also be perpendicular.
Otherwise, it would
change in such in a way
it's longer perpendicular.
OK?
So that's just
sort of intuitive.
Great.
What else?
I need it to be perpendicular
to something else.
I claim that n
prime of p is also
perpendicular to the rule line.
Ah, yes.
Because this normal-- all of
these points along a rule line
have the same normal direction.
These guys were all parallel.
And so if I look
at the change in n,
in order to make all
these guys be the same,
I also cannot change n in such a
way that it has a non-trivial--
I'm not going to
say this too well.
Do you believe it, more or less?
Let me try to say it once.
I'm looking at the
change in the normal.
I don't want the normal
to change in such a way
that it will change
along this axis.
So for that to be true,
the change in the normal
must be perpendicular
to this direction.
This is kind of weird
because the normal is also
perpendicular to this direction.
I mean, the normal
satisfies the same things.
It's perpendicular
to the boundary edge.
It's also perpendicular
to the rule line.
That means that n, the
normal, and its derivative,
they have the same direction.
That's weird.
In fact, it means that
the derivative must be 0.
Because the normal is
always unit length.
So this would be saying that
the normal is getting bigger
or shorter, but it
can't do either.
So in fact, normal's
not changing at all.
So in fact, all of
these guys are parallel
along the whole segment.
That means this
whole region is flat,
and that's a contradiction.
All right?
So I waved my hands a little
bit, especially on this step,
but believe me.
All right.
That's one fun fact,
but we want more.
Because how do we know that the
boundary would be polygonal?
For that we need that straight
creases remain straight.
And something's not true
when you have curve creases.
Curve creases obviously
don't remain curved.
But curve creases don't
even remain planar.
I mean, they can
do crazy things.
But straight creases
stay straight.
So what I mean is, I have
my flat piece of paper.
I take a straight line
in the piece of paper,
and I say that's
going to be a crease.
It has no first derivative
along the crease.
Then when I fold that,
I get a straight line
and some crazy stuff
on the other side,
but that crease
remains straight.
So I was in the
middle of the paper,
so it actually looks like this.
Remains a straight segment,
obviously of the same length.
But the point is it can't
curl, and it can't even kink.
Now, just any good theorem
needs a counter-example.
So if we take a piece of paper
and we make a straight crease,
look, I can curl that crease.
So this theorem is
not true unless I
say that the crease is proper.
So here I had to make the crease
all the way to 180 degrees,
then I can curl it.
Also, if I don't fold it
at all, then I can curl it.
But if it's folded something
in the middle, I cannot curl.
Paper will not be happy with me.
I need extra creases
in order to curl.
Well, yeah, it's
just not possible.
So proper crease, which
means the fold angle
is not equal to 0 or
plus or minus 180.
So that's the theorem.
Let's prove it.
Maybe go a little faster.
All right.
So we have our crease,
and in three dimensions
it might look curved.
We take some point.
We know that the paper is flat.
So if you look at the left
side and the right side
of the piece of paper,
locally, at least, it's flat.
And I want to think
of there being
some tangent plane
on the right side
and some tangent plane
on the left side.
Wow, that's not a good picture.
Let me draw the planes first.
So here's two planes, and
then here's my point p.
And locally the surface actually
lies in these two planes
and kinks here.
The surface kinks.
We want the crease
to be straight here,
but maybe the crease is
bent something like that.
All right.
Here's what we do.
Again, I want to think
of-- in this case,
I'm going to look at
tangents, not normals.
So I'm going to say, well,
every point on the curve
here has some tangent.
In fact, the tangent
at this point
must lie right along
the intersection
of these two planes.
I'm going to give
these planes names.
This is p.
This is going to be
tangent plane Tp,
and this is going to be
other tangent plane Sp,
so on the left and
the right side.
So the normal at p-- sorry, not
the normal, the tangent at p--
did I give it a name-- p prime.
That's what you'd
normally call it.
That's the derivative.
Tangent of p lies
along the intersection
of those two planes.
We don't really need
that, but it's true.
Give you some intuition.
Now, what I'm
really going to use
is the second derivative,
little more extreme here.
Second derivative is
curvature on the curve.
Now, we know that in
the unfolded surface,
there's exactly 180
degrees of material here.
Here's some point p.
We know there's 180
degrees of material.
I mean, locally, everything's
flat in terms of the surface.
So here's where I'm going to
wave my hands a little bit.
I claim that the
curvature vector
must be perpendicular to
Tp and perpendicular to Sp.
Because if I take this
curve, and I project it
into one of these
planes, say Tp,
it should be straight
at p in projection.
It also must be straight
when I project into Sp.
And that actually means
that it's straight
in three dimensions also.
So the straightness
and projection
corresponds to straightness
when flattened basically.
I'm waving my
hands a little bit.
But if I need the
curvature vector
to be perpendicular
to this plane--
so it's something like this.
It's coming straight
out of this plane.
But that uniquely
determines its direction.
It also needs to be
perpendicular to Sp.
These two vectors can't
be the same thing,
and yet they have to be, unless
these planes are the same.
So it could be there's a zero
fold angle, then it's fine.
Or it could be it's
180-degree fold angle,
then again the
planes are the same.
Can go in one
direction or the other.
But if I have a proper crease,
then there's no such vector.
And so we're done.
That proves straight
creases stay straight.
Cool.
Any questions about that?
So I'm trying to hit a
middle ground of not too
technical but also
not too shallow.
And so you're left in the middle
state of sort of make sense.
But I did wave my hands,
and it's not super rigorous.
Because to be rigorous
it would take forever,
and I need to teach you
differential geometry and so
on.
But now that we are
armed with these tools--
straight creases stay straight
and any polygonal boundary
stays flat, planar--
that tells us
that if we have
some crease pattern,
any crease pattern made
out of straight edges,
so no curve creases allowed,
if I make straight creases,
every single interior
face must stay rigid
in any proper folding.
That's pretty cool.
Because we've talked about
rigid origami and said not much
is known about rigid origami.
It's tough.
But in fact, you really need
to understand rigid origami
if you want to fold something
like a hyperbolic paraboloid.
Now, when you do flat
folding stuff-- well,
I guess those are
kind of rigid also.
But any kind of
3-dimensional folding,
where you fold every crease
somewhat but not all the way,
all the faces need to be
rigid in the final form.
Now, you could get there
by all sorts of means.
But we want the
hyperbolic paraboloid
to exist with creases
only along these lines.
And now we know each of these
trapezoids must remain planar.
Also, each of these
triangles must remain planar.
Now, now we get to
the contradictions.
If you have this piece
of paper and those
are your only creases,
you can fold along
one of the creases or
the other, but not both.
Unless you fold one crease
all the way to 180-- here,
we can do it.
I have one diagonal, and
I have another diagonal.
So everything's
meeting at 180 degrees.
I can fold one and
then the other.
I can fold one, or I
can fold the other.
But I cannot fold a
little bit of one,
and then try to
fold the other too.
It's not possible.
Therefore, this crease
pattern doesn't fold at all.
OK?
Kind of trivial.
The center is messed up.
But keep in mind,
again, these faces
we don't know anything about
because this edge could
do crazy things.
But the interior faces
of the crease pattern
must all stay flat
and stay exactly
as they were in the original.
So it's really like we
have rigid panels here
and hinges between them.
The outside, though, we
have no idea what happens.
OK.
So the inside sucks.
So I think, at this point,
we get to this picture.
Here's the regular
crease pattern.
So let's just make life
easier and say, well, we'll
cut out a hole in the center.
That surely-- that
must be better.
But it's no better.
That thing still
can't fold because you
take any of the rings
that goes around,
like a square annulus--
here's a ring.
The creases in that ring
are just those four.
So I'm just looking at
these four trapezoids.
Again, each one
must stay planar.
And these are the
only hinges I have.
It's actually really
just like this.
I've cut a hole in the
center, but it won't really
matter because the extension
of these lines meet at a point.
So effectively, you are
folding this whole triangle.
You can fold just the trapezoid.
But however you
fold the trapezoid,
you could just extend it
and make the triangle,
and these triangles
will remain meeting.
So it's actually the same
thing as the center diagram.
Because this doesn't fold,
this also won't fold.
It doesn't matter how
many layers you cut out.
As long as there's one
interior layer that
doesn't touch the boundary,
it's going to be screwed.
OK.
That is why
hyperbolic paraboloid
doesn't fold without diagonals.
Once you know the creases are
straight, it's kind of obvious.
But let me give you a
more general picture.
This makes things a little
more interesting and tells you,
really, all those
straight crease
pleatings that I've shown you,
like hexagons and octagons,
none of them are possible,
which was a surprise.
So here I'm taking concentric
shapes in such a way
that the diagonals
meet at a point.
I still need that fact.
If they don't, in fact,
it's possible to fold.
And we have a little
example of that.
OK, now I actually
need two interior rings
to get a contradiction.
So I take some ring like
this, and I take another ring,
and I suppose none of
them touch the boundary.
As long as I know
there's at least four,
there's going to be two
consecutive rings like this.
And the hinges are the diagonals
and the inner ring boundaries.
OK.
If I just look locally at
this, I claim it must be
mountain-mountain-mountain-valley
or the reverse.
This is something we would
normally prove by saying,
OK, this is locally smallest,
therefore these guys
are different.
And this is also
locally smallest,
therefore these guys are
different, and so on.
Except that only works
for flat folding.
Here I need to prove
it for 3D folding.
I'm not going to bother,
but you can do it.
So in fact, let's say this is
mountain-mountain-mountain-valley,
then this must be
mountain, this must,
all the way around
must be mountain.
OK?
That's not such a big deal.
This must all be valley,
and this must all
be mountain, or
the entire reverse.
But the point is,
all of these guys
out here must be mountains.
So really if I extend
all of these guys
and they meet at a single
point, if I was lucky,
that's what I'm supposed to
assume, really what I'm doing
is folding a whole
bunch of triangles
where all of the
creases are mountains.
That's not possible.
So if you didn't
believe this thing,
it follows from
the same argument.
They can't all be mountains,
and therefore some crease
is not getting folded.
So it's the same
argument again, you just
have to be a little
more precise.
And that is not folding
hyperbolic paraboloids
and things like that.
But if you had
diagonals, it all works.
Now, in the last few minutes, I
want to show you some more fun
things, in particular, pillows.
Everybody likes pillows.
But how are they made?
Well, it's like two
squares of material joined
along the edges, and then
you stuff stuff inside.
That kind of weird, because
doubly-covered square I
think of as flat, and yet
you can put material inside.
What is the maximum volume
you can stuff into a pillow?
This is called the
tea bag problem
because it also works
for square tea bags.
Open.
We don't know.
Lots of practical
explorations, but open.
Another version of
this is Mylar balloons.
Mylar balloons can't
stretch, more or less.
And here is two
circles glued together.
Again flat, but you
can pump air into them.
You get this weird behavior,
these ripples on the outside.
That's real stuff.
But we don't know what the
maximum volume shape is,
but it should look something
like what we see in reality.
Let me tell you
some fun theorems.
If you take any convex
polyhedron, like say a cube,
you can inflate it and
increase its volume.
Also, I guess, works for
a doubly-covered square.
This is the tea
bag open problem,
where these edges are joined.
How do you do it?
I'm going to quote
from the paper--
"by simultaneously
delivering karate chops
to the edges of the polyhedron."
That's in the abstract.
So you take an edge like
this-- here's an edge
and the two incident
faces-- and I go like this.
Wow, that was exciting.
So what happens when you go like
this-- the whole board shakes,
I'll probably break
it eventually--
you get something like that.
So there's a valley
here, and then
mountains there to
replace this mountain.
And you can prove, if you do
that with suitable parameters
here, at every edge
simultaneously you
increase the volume,
which is pretty neat.
Now, how far can you go?
What happens when you keep
increasing the volume?
Is the limit polyhedral, or
is it smooth with ripples?
Conjecture is it's
smooth with ripples.
In fact, you can prove
it's not polyhedral.
Because not only for
convex polyhedral,
you take any polyhedron, it
is possible to inflate it
by at least some volume.
So the limit has to be curvy.
It's not going to be polyhedral.
Now, exactly what
it looks like we
don't know, but lots of
experiments to that effect.
A big open question in this
field is, does this exist?
We think so.
It seems curve creases--
none of this stuff
works for curve creases.
Curve creases seem
a lot more powerful.
We haven't been able
to prove this exists
because it seems very flexible.
There's a lot of
degrees of freedom.
It's hard to figure out
where the rule lines are.
But we think so.
So what about curved creases?
I haven't talked
about curve creases
really at all
until this lecture.
I would say the most seminal
work in curve creases
was done by David Huffman.
Huffman is super famous.
He was a grad student
and a professor
here at MIT for many years.
In particular, when
he was a grad student
he came up with
these Huffman codes,
which are used in
every MP3 player.
Every device you use that
uses any kind of compression
has Huffman codes in it.
Super cool from the '60s.
But he also did a lot
of curve crease origami,
curve crease folding.
And over the last
couple of years,
we've been working with
his family, so his wife
and two daughters,
Linda and Elise.
And this is me,
that's Marty, and this
is Duks Koschitz,
who many of you
know is a PhD student
in architecture.
And we were visiting there
back in May in particular.
And what we're doing is
taking his work, which
is all in their houses and
almost no one has seen,
and figuring out
how he made them.
What is the underlying
mathematics?
What are the crease patterns
that make it possible?
And then recreating them to
check that we did it right.
So what I have here are just a
few examples of our recreations
so far.
So these are not
the original models,
but they look just like
made out of the same material
and more or less the same way.
Although we do it a little
more high-tech than he
did because we want to draw
perfect computational diagrams
in CAD, and then
reproduce them exactly
on the paper with no
reproduction errors.
So we use fancy
robotically-controlled devices
to do that.
So there's some
fun curve creases.
You get some really
nice shadow patterns.
All of those are circular
arcs, all the creases.
Here are some more.
These are actually parabolic
arcs and some straight creases
in between.
Get some cool 3D relief effect.
These are like
tessellations like Tom Hull
was talking about but
with curve creases.
This is pretty awesome.
Here the creases are quite
complicated to figure out.
But what's happening is
you're taking a cone like this
and pleating it back and forth
but with different angles,
and so the whole thing twists.
We have a physical one
of these in our offices.
But this is the 3D model
of what's going on.
Here's some particularly
awesome crease patterns.
David Huffman made a
whole variety of these.
These are just a
couple of examples.
Got some crazy circular arcs.
You've got some-- I
guess these are also
circular arcs and some
straight segments.
And then you wrap this
around to make a cylinder,
and you get this.
That one-- there's a bunch of
photos of the original David
Huffman model on the web
if you Google around.
Not looking exactly like that,
but there's a whole variety.
Here's another one,
a bit of a maybe
surprise what it looks like.
Most of the center just gets
eaten away from these creases.
Here the creases are
elliptical, and you
get something like that.
So there's some hidden
structure beneath.
I think just one more example.
This is probably the
most coolest puzzle.
You say, well, you float along
these parabolas, just one
valley and one mountain.
But you fold them a
lot, you get that.
And Huffman composed
these to make
various kinds of tubes
and really cool things.
So this is work in progress.
Just wanted to
give you a sample.
There's a paper about this
which shows more examples.
But our goal is to recreate
all or most of them
and document how he
did it and figure out
how he designed these models.
He had mathematical
tools to do this,
and we're still figuring
out what they are.
The hope is it will lead to
more great mathematics and art
about curve creases.
And that is it.
This is my last lecture.
Next class we have-- or
next three classes we
have a whole bunch of
student presentations.
Please come.
There will be lots of
awesome things there.
Send me your slides
ahead of time,
and you'll have 10 minutes
to do it, to give a talk.
And then the last lecture,
Wednesday two weeks from now,
is Tomohiro Tachi.
And thanks very much.
It's been a lot of
fun doing this class
and having you all as students.
[APPLAUSE]